في العاصمه التونسيه مسيره بدعوه من نشطاء
وحقوقيين احتجاجا على تعرض المهاجرين من
دول الافريقيه في تونس لما وصف بتعامل
العنصري واجبت المسيره شوارع العاصمه
وصولا الى الشارع الحبيب بورقيبه حيث ندد
المتظاهرون بما وصفوه بالخطاب الرسمي
العنصري الذي يستهدف هذه الفئه كما
طالبوها سلطات باستجابه انسانيه لتسويه
اوضاع اعداد من هؤلاء المهاجرين ممن ليست
لديهم وثائق اقامه وكان الرئيس قيس سعيد
قد تحدث في وقت سابق عن ضروره وضع حد
لتدفق المهاجرين الافارقه الجنوبيه
الصحراء الى البلاد وصفه وصول اعداد كبيره
منهم لانه مؤامره لتغيير التركيبه
الديموغرافيه بتونس
نقلت وكاله الانباء الرسميه التونسيه عن
مصدر امليا عدد المهاجرين من دول افريقيا
جنوبها الصحراء والذين تم ايقافهم خلال
المده الاخيره بولايه اريانا بتونس
العاصمه يفوق ثلاثه مئه شخص
وكانت مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي قد قالت
انها تدين بالشده تصريحات التي وصفتها
بالعنصريه
واستهدفت مهاجرين افارقه في تونس وقالت في
بيان انه جرائب له ممثله تونس بصدمه
المفوضيه وقلقها من استهداف مواطنين
افارقه بغض النظر عن وضعهم القانونيه في
البلاد
وقد لفت داخليه التونسيه شمس السلطات
الامنيه حمله ايقافات بحق المهاجرين على
راضيها واكدت حرصها على حمايه حقوقهم من
جانبها عبرتها الخارجيه عن استغرابها من
البيان الصادر عن مفاوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي حول وضعيه الجاليه الافريقيه
بتونس ورفضت ما ورد به من عباراتهم
واتهامات قالت انه لا اساس لها من الصحه
واعتبرت الخارجيه ان موقف المخوضيه بني
على فهم خاطئ لمواقف السلطات التونسيه